So he's had a couple of flops, well, who hasn't?
You have a new book in mind?
Of course he does!
My lamp's gone out, I've ran out of ideas.
Are we in trouble?
No, of course not.
I have told you not to disturb me when I am working.
On Christmas Eve, the spirits pour into the night.
Well here, Mr. Dickens, pickpockets, streetwalkers, humbug...
Those people don't belong in books.
Charles...
Humbug!
How do you make a world come alive, I could almost see and hear them people?
Even if you've already written it, we couldn't possibly get it printed and distributed...
...in only six weeks.
If I can't finish it, I'll never write again.
The characters won't do what I want.
I'm the author here.
Allegedly.
A jolly ghost?
What's that mean?
This season of hope, we will shut out nothing and everyone will be welcome.
I have to get to the printers by nine o'clock.
But you still don't have an ending.
Merry, merry Christmas to one and all.
Merry Christmas!